this world in frozen 2 is so expensive
this film in particular is really epic
and you know it really expands the
frozen universe to go to this beautiful
enchanted forest and we go to the dark
seas it's very different and it's much
further from arendelle it's beyond the
Ice Palace this is visually I think the
most complex and most exciting thing
we've ever attempted you know from the
first film we we all felt we knew these
characters very well it's been three
years since we've seen him last and the
characters have matured what's fun about
that is that we get to revisit these
characters who we know and as animators
we we really feel connected to not only
have we all matured as artists and grown
up with this the silhouettes of the the
models have all become more
sophisticated the ability to grow plants
and trees have become more sophisticated
the lighting apparatus has become more
sophisticated so all of us have grown
with it and all the tools have grown
where did you learn magic during the
pre-production period of a film we're
doing a lot of research and we are
trying to figure out what are the big
technical and creative challenges of the
film one thing that was really
particular about this film is how much
collaboration was needed to be able to
pull it off there are so many things
that are put into each character each
costume each piece of the world we have
these different elemental characters or
water horse and these are the Giants and
Gale that's kind of like this wind
spirit the stories coming into being at
the same time that we're trying to
design so for a long time its
exploration and trying to figure out
what what it is that we're all trying to
say and that takes a lot of work and a
lot of collaboration so I think our
daily ritual is a lot more integrated
with the other departments then and
previous on that we drive done quick
question it's the whole putting up some
Mortal games are gonna be a regular
thing
we wanted to go with more of a fall and
autumn palette this time basically to
sort of support the story as our
characters are maturing and changing we
felt that autumn was that season that
sort of matures and changes that year is
changing we went to Finland Norway
Iceland and Finland Norway very much of
the old fairy tales and folklore of
Scandinavia that had a lot of influence
into our traditional fairy tales and
then went to Iceland which very much
tied into the mythic world of Elsa's
powers and the power of nature being so
great and really in charge and it felt
fun to imagine Elsa in an environment
where nature was maybe more powerful as
she is magic is very alluring without
you know there's a lot of beautiful
large landscapes on this film so IMAX I
think would be an amazing way to view it
we wanted to go bigger grittier with the
palette grittier with the world like
welcome to the real world kids kind of
feeling that's what happens as you're
growing up I think it's gonna be pretty
pretty immersive it's just gorgeous and
really pulled you and to see it in the
world of iMac like I can't wait to
experience it it'll be an experience
[Music]
you